In the debugging demo, Ki, noted that the word hello, got truncated to hell.
The place where text is set is in the constructor, so something must be wrong
in this constructor. Let me set a break point to check it out. I just clicked
next to the line I want to stop on. Now, if I run the syllable counter, give it
hello yellow peach and hit Enter. It pops up my debugger, and my code shows the
line that the debugger is stopped on. So far, not a whole lot has happened.
We've just converted S to lower case and put it in text. I want to skip these
loops and get to the juicy part and figure out what they computed. So, I'll
just single step until I get to the last line. Try that out. What will the
local variables, i and j be equal to if you step all the way to this last line?
You'll really need to do this in BlueJ because the Udacity IDE doesn't have a
debugger. So, if you run syllable counter and enter hello yellow peach and then
step to the last line of the constructor, what is the value of I? How about j?